speeding action hi I'm Arnold
Schwarzenegger that's right Arnold
Schwarzenegger you're probably wondering
where's my thick Austrian accent gone
thanks to axagon the accent eliminating
spray it's terminated yeah one thing you
need to know Arnold uh can we can we go
again I thought that was good uh yeah it
was great but um your accent creeped in
a little bit and we can't have any
really yeah just just hexagon the accent
eliminating spray it's terminated
it works naturally into Arnold
um can we can we just start from the top
why is that thanks to a revolutionary
all-natural throat spray well it works
fast
uh it happened again yeah yeah so let's
just start again okay and I don't know
what you're hearing and action a
revolutionary new throat spray called
hexagon will completely eliminate your
accent guaranteed okay cut really after
just two weeks of use yeah I
accidentally completely eliminate what
hexagon is a throat
do this let's start let's start over
okay
check out some of these lines accent
free it's not a tumor get in the chopper
cohagen give them their air who is your
daddy who the hell and what does he do
who's your daddy who is your daddy
well I hope you left enough room for my
fist because I'm going to ram it into
your stomach and rip out your goddamn
spine
with hexagon I guarantee your accent
will never say I'll be back I'll be bad
never say I'll be big I'll be back I'll
be back
yeah your accent will never fly
I personally are you are you all right
yeah you know what let's go with us all
right I'm ready
all right we are rolling and action well
you
I am a governor of California I'll be
back hexagon available at finer
pharmacies this
cookies
[Music]